c'est une mauvaise réponse à une bonne
question alexis c'est une affaire un peu
jésuites donc ça devrait faire pierre
olivier s'était fait un peu 18 on met en
avant la question de sécurité des
travailleurs la question n'est pas là
celle de la sécurité travaillant pour
qu'elle puisse se poser la question
c'est de dire il faut stopper les
travailleurs détachés au départ cet
effet par wauquiez et par pécresse pour
lancer un cri d'alarmé en disant arrêtez
ce système fou dont tout le monde
reconnaît depuis des années qu'il est
fou de ces travailleurs qui sont payés
ce d'alpiq social qui fait des
travailleurs coûtent beaucoup moins
c'est beaucoup moins cher pour des
employeurs français d'utiliser de la
main d'oeuvre étrangère parce que les
charges sociales sont pas les mêmes dans
leur pays sur le fond toujours d'accord
y compris mâcon puisque mac en partie
devant l'europe se bagarrer en disant il
faut revoir ses arrières dh et c'est ce
système est insupportable ça veut dire
qu'il a compris quelque chose là dessus
le problème c'est qu'il a eu que très
très très très partiellement gain de
cause parce que la vérité c'est que au
fond les allemands n'en veulent pas
parce qu'ils ont besoin de main d'oeuvre
que les pires en veulent encore moins
parce qu'ils ont besoin d'envoyer leurs
manoeuvres et que donc l'europe pour ne
pas faire perdre la face à macro ont dit
on va revoir le truc on va prendre
quelques années il ya un an
oui non limitant en limite la durée
maximale supérieure à la durée moyenne
aujourd'hui de l'emploi des travailleurs
détachés et on exclut les traces donc le
problème est entier et donc la riposte
qui restent à wauquiez avait cassé c'est
de trouver ce bien mais biais dont on
peut contester le caractère g8 mais qui
quittent décidé à répondre à un vrai
problème